No vabbè ma come l'hanno conciata No ma
ti prego questo abito non la valorizza
per niente Poi cos'è il carnevale di Rio
ti presenti a Sanremo scalza Ok il
concetto Ma che concetto è poi non è
manco in palet Cioè non puoi indossare
quel colore se sei Winter Cool dai
licenziate questo stylist cos'è sto
capello unto Ma ti pregoo non è weter
quelli sono oiler sai invece io cosa G
avrei fatto indossare qualcosa con un
po' più di carattere capito i Magari
Avrei giocato un po' di più con i volumi
dei giochi di organza tulle oppure non
so una gonna stile Vittoriano capito
sbam un po' come l'ultima sfilata di
Gela tipo non avrei caricato così tanto
il makeup occhi neri da Panda e la bocca
rossa stile Joker uno l'altro o Panda o
Joker